Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Lisa Cousins. I am currently in
Oregon at Oregon Health & Science University.
I hope you're enjoying this wonderful meeting, and it is
my absolute honor and pleasure
to
introduce
the awardee for the Princess Takamatsu
Memorial Lectureship today, Dr. David Lydon.
I had the absolute honor and privilege of chairing the committee this year
in honor of the late princess. And
at this point, it is my great honor to
introduce Dr. Murakami, who presently
holds
the
chair of the committee in Japan for the late Princess
Takamatsu. Dr. Murakami.
Okay.
Thank you very much, Dr. Cousins, for your kind introduction.
And on behalf of the Princess Takamatsu Cancer Research Fund, I would
like to express my sincere gratitude to Dr.
Lilian Siu, Dr. Margaret Foti, and Dr.
Lisa Cousins, and all the committee members of
AACR for organizing this AACR Princess
Takamatsu Memorial Lectureship at this annual
meeting of AACR. And also, I would like to
congratulate Dr. David Lydon for being awarded
this year's awardee of the
AACR Princess Takamatsu
Memorial Lectureship. This is... Okay.
Hmm?
That's my slides.
What is my slide?
Please.
You'll have to ask Lisa. My slides.
Oh, your slide. So sorry.
Those are David's slides. Right.
Mm-hmm.
Did you upload slides?
Yes.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I don't know if they... Can you tell them back there?
There we go.
Oh, that one.
Start.
Yeah. That one.
Oh, sorry. Thank you very much.
So
I'd like to take this opportunity to briefly introduce the
late Her Imperial Highness Princess Takamatsu, Kikuko Takamatsu,
and the Princess Takamatsu Cancer Research Fund.
About 170 years ago, in
1854, Japan had
opened our country to the Western world.
But before that,
Japan was an isolated country ruled by samurai
and their king called the shogun. And
Princess Kikuko Takamatsu was born as a
granddaughter of the last shogun,
Yoshinobu Tokugawa. Okay. And in 1930,
she married Prince Takamatsu, the younger brother
of the Emperor Showa, and they took the luxurious
honeymoon trip to USA and Europe. But
shortly after her come back to Japan,
she lost her mother at the age of
43 by colon cancer. Since then,
Princess Takamatsu has dedicated much of her life
to alleviating the scourge or burden
of cancer.
So she established in 1968, the Princess
Takamatsu Cancer Research Fund and invited outstanding
scientists from overseas to her palace.
And this international symposium has been held annually in
Tokyo since 1970. And every time,
20 distinguished scientists from abroad and
10 from Japan are invited as speakers.
And Dr. Margaret Foti
of AACR
met Princess Takamatsu on several occasions
at her palace. Here is Dr. Margaret
Foti, looks exactly the same as today.
But anyway, Dr. Foti has made a great
contribution to
Princess Takamatsu's general support for cancer
research internationally.
As one of the symbolic example is
the January 1st, 1992, issue of "Cancer
Research," and they featured
the photograph of Princess Takamatsu in full dress on the
cover.
And after making a great dedicated
contribution to cancer research, Princess Takamatsu
passed away in 2004.
And three years later,
in 2007, AACR and the fund has
established this lectureship at the
annual meeting of the AACR. So aim is
to recognize an individual scientist whose noble and
significant work has made a great contribution to
prevention, diagnosis, and treatment cancer, and also who
embodies the dedication shown by Princess Takamatsu to international
cooperation. And here is a list of the
awardees, including Dr. Lisa Cousins in
2018.
And since 2012,
His Imperial Highness Prince Hitachi
has been the patron of this fund. He himself
is established cancer biologist of fish, and he's a
younger brother and the uncle of the emperor anyway.
And to carry-carry forward the
wishes of Princess Takamatsu. All the activities has
been continued to be supported by Prince and
Princess Hitachi now.
And on behalf of the Princess Takamatsu Cancer Research Fund, I'd be
very pleased to announce that this year's awardee
is Dr. David Lyden, Weill Cornell Medicine,
and for his great contribution to cancer research on
his outstanding discovery of cancer
metastasis niche,
and also the extracellular vesicles.
So we all are looking forward to Dr.
Lyden's lecture. Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you so much, Dr. Murakami. On behalf of the officers
and directors of the AACR, we are deeply grateful to you
and to your colleagues at the Princess Takamatsu Cancer Research Fund for
your ongoing partnership and generous support of this very
special lectureship. Thank you. This award means a great
deal to the AACR, and we are extremely proud to be able to work
with you and your colleagues to present this award each year to the greatest
scientists in the world. Thank you.
This lectureship recognizes scientists whose novel and
significant research has led to or may have a
far-reaching impact on the detection, diagnosis, treatment,
and prevention of cancer.
Such individuals must also embody the dedication shown by
Princess Takamatsu to establishing multinational
collaborations. This year's honoree is a
distinguished physician-scientist whose research has
significantly enhanced and advanced our understanding of
cancer and who has demonstrated a strong commitment
to international collaboration.
It is my great pleasure to present the
2026 AACR Princess Takamatsu Memorial
Lectureship to Dr. David Lyden of Weill Cornell
Medicine.
Dr. Lyden is being recognized for his pioneering
work as a physician-scientist
whose research has fundamentally reshaped our understanding of
metastasis. As a professor of pediatrics and
pediatric neuro-oncology, he has led transformative
discoveries defining how cancers spread and
interact systemically,
excuse me, with the body.
Early in his career, Dr. Lyden demonstrated the role of
bone marrow-derived cells in supporting tumor growth and
dissemination. He then introduced one of the most
influential concepts in modern cancer biology, the
pre-metastatic niche, and then demonstrated that
primary tumors condition distant organs that are
thereby receptive to metastatic cells, where he
then established the critical role of tumor-derived
exosomes. His research has demonstrated that
extracellular vesicles carry specific molecular
cargo that prime distant tissues, effectively
preparing them as sites for tumor colonization.
These findings have launched the modern field of exosome biology
in cancer and provided a mechanistic explanation
for how metastasis is orchestrated at the systemic level
via his identification of integrin ZIP codes on
exosomes that determine organ-specific
metastasis, impact metabolic dysfunction
in subsequent metastatic sites, and contribute to
complications such as thrombosis,
providing new insights into a major cause of cancer-related
mortality, all of which has opened new avenues for therapeutic
intervention with profound implications for
translational
impact.
In addition to his profound scientific achievements,
Dr. Lyden is a dedicated mentor and leader in the
academic community, where he is committed to training the next
generation of clinician-scientists.
Dr. Lyden has received numerous honors, including the
Paget-Ewing Award from the Metastasis Research Society and
the Special Achievement Award from the International Society of
Extracellular Vesicles.
It is my great honor to introduce you to the
2026 recipient of the AACR Princess
Takamatsu Memorial Lectureship, Dr. David Lyden.
Great. Thank you so much, Professor Murakami.
And Lisa, that was really such kind introduction.
Thank you. So as Lisa mentioned,
cancer is a systemic disease. And
so,
we have to really realize that we have to go beyond the primary
tumor. And when you see a cancer patient as a
physician, you realize all the problems that
patient has.
And so one of the explanations for the crosstalk
between the tumor and these systemic organs are
extracellular vesicles and particles, which are size
of viruses, approximately 35 nanometers
to 150 nanometers in sizeAnd the
tumor and the tumor microenvironment is
secreting trillions of these EVs, as
we call them, into the circulation.
So the first part I'm going to show you is that some of these
EVs have direction, as Lisa mentioned, zip codes
that go to certain organs that promote
organotropic metastases.
And more so, they're going to other organs, causing
a lot of the systemic effects of cancer that we're
realizing more and more with their contribution.
Those are my disclosures.
So now it's over 20 years ago when we first
described the pre-metastatic niche, and this is Rosie,
Rebecca, and Stergios. And together we
studied tumors, especially melanoma on the skin,
and we were studying bone marrow-derived cells.
Here we noticed that these bone marrow immune-suppressed cells
were going to the lung, so far away.
And so how can the melanoma communicate with these
cells? And when the tumors enter the lung,
they always land exactly in these places, not in
the normal blue areas of the lung.
So as I mentioned, how does a tumor so far away
communicate and establish a pre-metastatic site?
And we know there's a lot of tumor-secreted factors that are involved,
but one of these groups are the extracellular vesicles
that we clearly found at pre-metastatic sites.
And here you could see
exosome is another name for it. That's
approximately 100 and 150 nanometers, but there's
smaller ones. And then there's these teeny little
particles without a double lipid bilayer that we
eventually coined and named exomeres.
And together, they really can do a lot
of damage promoting metastases. And
as you will see, they can promote
thrombosis as well as shut down the
liver, as examples for today.
So you see this whole world of extracellular vesicles.
Every day, there's a new size particle being discovered.
The larger ones like to break off the surface,
and so they have their own unique cargo being
packaged in size.
And here we've studied the smaller ones, the smaller
extracellular vesicles called exosomes that
originate near the nucleus and are packaged in these
multivesicular bodies that are eventually
released into the circulation. And
finally, the smallest one, there's exomeres, and now there's
another smaller group called supermeres,
and we don't know exactly where their origin is, but we suspect
that the mitochondria is involved in their
biogenesis.
So here's a diagram of an extracellular vesicle.
And what's nice about these vesicles is that most
proteins and unique lipids and even the
DNA is presented on the
transmembrane site. So they make great
biomarkers and targets, and so keep that
in mind. But today, I'm really
focusing on their function, what they do systemically.
So can they prepare an organ for distant
metastases? And we heard throughout the
meetings about Stephen Paget, who first
described in 1889 the seed and the soil
hypothesis. He was a British
surgeon working in breast cancer, and he couldn't figure
out why his patients, some would have liver mets, and others
would have brain mets, and others would have bone mets.
And so he felt we needed to study the seed, which is the tumor
cells.
But he also suggested that we should consider the
soil because they're going to specific organ
sites. And not too many people studied the
soil and listened to him until a few of us,
about 30 years ago,
started studying the metastatic soil.
So if we isolate these extracellular
vesicles, we can do that by cell lines,
tissues that you put in culture, a number of
sources. All cells are releasing them.
But here we're using the triple-negative breast cancer
parental and subclones. These
subclones specifically go to certain organs like the bone,
the lung, and the brain. And so we're growing them in culture.
We isolate the media, and we use
ultrasentrifugation to spin them down.
And now we could label them with lipophilic dyes and
inject them intravenously in a naive mouse, a mouse
who never saw tumor exosomes beforehand.
And so now we're using Odyssey imaging of the lung.
And after the injection of these
EVs, you could see the EVs from the
lung-tropic cells are all going to the lung and
fusing and forming little niches in
the lung. And you don't see the exosomes from the
brain-tropic cells or the bone-tropic cells, for the
most part, going to the lungIf we image the
brain, then the EVs from the brain tropic cells are
going to the brain. So this was very encouraging
to us that EVs, in part, do have a role
in organotropism.
And how they do that, as Lisa mentioned, is the zip codes.
And it turns out the integrins in particular,
after we do proteomics for all the proteins,
are in a particular
network for each type of cell and their
EVs. Interestingly, the integrins
are not just representing those in the cells.
They're specifically packaged, so we're still trying to figure out the cell
biology, how that happens. But
already if we collect EVs from the blood or from the
tissue, and they have an EV that's alpha V
beta 5, we already know that those are going to
potentially go to the liver and fuse with Kupffer
cells there.
So another integrin pattern is alpha 6 beta 4 and
alpha 6 beta 1, and those integrins like to fuse with
epithelial cells, macrophages, and a number
of cells in the lung.
If we see an integrin alpha V beta 3,
that integrin likes to fuse with cells in the brain, in
particular microglia and endothelial cells.
We also found a protein that was brain tropic, that
hyaluronic acid binding protein called CMIP as
well.
So all these extracellular vesicles and
exosomes are very important
in studying the pre-metastatic niche.
But we're also excited that there's other groups that
have now
really are studying this pre-metastatic niche,
such as those with the microbiome and metabolic
reprogramming and whether or not extracellular
vesicles and exosomes have a role.
So it's at a very exciting time studying this
pre-metastatic niche and the potential of preventing
metastases.
It's very exciting to see the work come to the
clinical side of things after 20 years.
And so can we detect these pre-metastatic sites in
patients?
And so this is happening in probably 10 centers
now. We started this work getting biopsies,
say, for the liver in patients with pancreatic
cancer. We then do cellular molecular metabolic
profiling of this tissue, and we could
predict
your outcome, and we followed these patients over eight years.
So if the patient in the liver had a lot of NETS, neutrophil
extracellular traps, working with Nicola Engelblade,
this was the worst scenario possible, and you would have
metastases in three months. So now there's groups
studying the omentum and liver and
colon cancer,
and actually people are getting lung tissue for renal
cell carcinoma, see if they can actually
predict future metastases.
So another very exciting area is radiomics,
and this is a surgical group at Memorial Sloan Kettering,
taking CAT scans of the liver for their patients
with pancreatic cancer.
And eventually they have different pixel
patterns that they were able to predict
who was going to metastasize or not.
A lot of these pixels are influenced by
forces with work of Valerie Weaver and
extracellular matrix components.
Also, the secreted factors are not only in the primary
tumor. These pre-metastatic sites secrete a lot of
different factors. Here's one of our papers showing
that the interstitial macrophage in the lung, a future
site of metastases, secretes very high
IL-6, where the primary tumor did not secrete
this factor. So this is all coming
together. And what's really exciting is
actually companies are now paying attention to the
pre-metastatic niche. They want to develop
drugs that block metastases, and here's a number
of companies that advertise blocking the pre-metastatic
niche with inflammation, ECM, and
metabolism as
targets.
So we mentioned how EVs and
particles have a role in establishing
pre-metastatic sites,
but we have to really be aware that there's a lot of
non-metastatic organs that are involved when you have cancer.
Can the EVPs have a role at this stage?
And here's a nice diagram showing this is exactly what
happens with a cancer patient.
So the tumor and all its secreted factors,
which really I think should be a hallmark of cancer,
have a huge impact systemically. So we
have muscle and heart waste and fat
wasting, known as cachexia. We have a lot of things
going on in the brain that not too many people are studying.
Patients present with seizures, memory loss,
depressionLisa Coussens has worked
so much on the systemic effects of the immune system,
and now we know that the EVPs are
influencing your immune cells.
Diabetes, people are presenting,
that's often a sign of cancer exosomes influencing the
pancreas.
And now today, I'm going to be talking about how
EVPs are involved with thrombosis and
shutting down the liver, causing fatty liver and
metabolic dysregulation.
So this is how we should think, all of us, whether you're a
researcher or a clinician.
You have pancreatic cancer. You just can't think,
"Let me deal with the pancreatic tumor."
Here we know the exosomes are going to the liver, as I just
showed you, in patients with biopsy-proven
evidence. So we call this a pre-metastatic liver
niche. But are the other major organs,
like the lung here, normal?
So every patient that has gastric cancer, colorectal
cancer, all the GI cancers, we should be asking,
what is the liver doing? But more
importantly, also, what is the lung doing?
Is the lung normal?
And it turns out pancreatic cancer and all the other
GI cancers secrete enormous levels
of this chemokine CXCL13.
This chemokine has great influence on the lung
and can influence the interstitial macrophages there,
which support clot formation. So now we have a
pre-metastatic liver,
but we also have concerns of a pro-thrombotic lung
niche. And we have evidence of this in
patients.
Patients with gastroesophageal cancer are on
immune therapy. They actually can eliminate all
the liver metastases, but all the patients now are
dying of thrombosis. We are not targeting this
arm of the problem.
And there's other tumors that have much lower,
explaining why they're low on the thrombosis list,
like breast cancer and melanoma.
Those tumors have to actually metastasize to the lung
and sit next to the interstitial macrophage, where
they release little bits of
CXCL4 and then cause
metastases.
So the whole work is tumors are secreting this
chemokine influencing interstitial macrophage.
And surprisingly, we have another extracellular vesicle
now being
supported in production expressing beta-2
integrin. These can bind platelets and form
clots.
So all this work was done by Serena
Lucati, who's here today, and a very
talented instructor in the lab. And so she
demonstrated all these pathways, and she
could also isolate lung tissue
from pancreatic cancer.
And then she isolates these exosomes and put it in
naive mice, and she can cause massive clotting.
So normal lung EVs are from
another organ, or for that matter, any other metastatic
organ like liver or bone,
they do not cause clots. The cells have to originate
from these interstitial macrophages in the lung,
and you could see there's massive clot formation when she puts it
in naive mice.
Here she's isolating lung tissue in melanoma that's
metastasized,
and she then injects EVs in naive
mice. Here you could see right away in
minutes the formation of clots and all the exosomes
that are part of the clot.
So if they're expressing this beta-2 integrin, Serena
then treated the mice, let melanoma
grow for a week, and then she did six injections
up to four weeks with the antibody that targets this
beta-2 integrin. She was pleased to say the
fibrin levels went down, the platelet count
in the periphery went up. Those are all good signs of
preventing clot formation.
But what she found, like science, an unexpected
finding. She actually treated mice with well
advanced disease, and
after several courses of this late-stage
melanoma, she was able to reverse the
burden.
And here you could see it in
gross histology. And so this was
very exciting and we're now
marketing towards developing this
beta-2 integrin. Can we treat not only clots,
but we're hoping we actually can treat metastatic disease.
Here, even more detailed, is a nanoimager that images
single vesicles.
And so here's vesicles from the original
tumorThis is the stain for the vesicle.
These are beta-2 integrins, and they're
scattered about on the surface of this
vesicle. However, when you have
pancreatic cancer or tissue in
melanoma, the lung part not involving the cancer, she
isolates the exosomes. And you could see they're all
clustered for the beta-2 integrin.
And it's in this structural format
that is found that now can bind
platelets. So not only is it the president of the protein, but it
has to be presented in a specific structure in
order for it to interact with binding partners.
And where's the source of this CXCL13?
It's coming from the tumor cells like pancreatic cancer, but we know
like some of these aggressive cancers that
metastasize have very high CAFs,
sometimes up to 90% of the tumor, and they are
also releasing this chemokine.
Clinically, when we measure
EVs that express beta-2 integrin, we can predict
which patients in the pancreatic cancer realm, who's
going to form clots. And this is a huge problem for these
patients, especially if you're going to surgery and they develop a
clot, they could die very easily.
And so we were blinded, and this level
predicted all the patients that were going to have clots.
And here, after the clot, their beta-2 level went
down partially.
Excitingly, we also got lung tissue.
So here's pancreatic cancer in the lung.
You could see it's not staining for beta-2.
It really is the interstitial macrophage.
And now this whole area here is a
non-metastatic lung and pancreatic cancer patient.
You could see it's not
normal whatsoever, that it's loaded not just
with clots, but huge amounts of
proliferative interstitial macrophages that are really
blocking all the
air exchange sites.
So these patients really should also have
pulmonary function testing, even though there's no
metastases in the lung.
So the zip codes for these integrins is
expanding. Not only can they predict organotropic
metastases, but now they give us hints on
other systemic effects like thrombosis.
But all of us now have to, as again,
even researchers, we should be asking, okay, I'm not
studying pancreatic cancer. I study osteosarcoma,
breast cancer, melanoma, renal cell carcinoma.
And if Dr. Lydon's correct, then the exosomes for
them would go to the lung and form pre-metastatic
lung niche, and that's what they do.
You see NETs formation, and I'm
simplifying things. There's a lot of other things going on in this
pre-metastatic lung. But now we ask, is the
liver normal in these patients?
And first of all, when we get EVs,
we see a collection like this.
We developed an updated AF4
analysis, so that's like putting these particles in a
swimming pool on one side, applying parallel and
perpendicular forces, and the small little
exomeres, as we call them, reach the other side of the pool
quickly,
and we can collect them. And this is followed by the
exosome small, which are 60 to 80 nanometers,
and the large. Now we could ask, these are the three
different vesicles and particles we see at
distant organ sites. What contribution do they
have? Well, the exomeres contain all these
metabolic proteins, and if you do pathway
analysis on these proteins, you have glycolysis
and mTOR signaling.
We now want to know if you put them in mice
intravenously,
and we gave just one injection, and 24 hours later, we look
what organs are taking them up.
Well, the exosome large vesicles are taken up by
lymph nodes. Do they promote lymph node
metastases? Do they interact with the immune system?
It looks like they're the predominant players of the three.
The exosome small go to distant organ sites.
This is melanoma, so it's not surprising they go to the
lung, and do they promote lung metastases?
But what's really surprising for us was the
exomeres. They, more than the other
two, are going to the liver. What are they doing
there with all their metabolic information?
So here's our team. Gang Wang led this study.
He now has his own lab and doing well at Peking
University.
And so no one's looking at the liver in all these models all these
years. You put melanoma in, you put
osteosarcoma.
I now went back to all the surgeons at Sloan Kettering who are
working on osteosarcoma. I said, "Didn't you notice the kids'
livers?" And they said they were always yellow, and they
never could figure out why.And so
what we're finding in these livers when we do RNA-seq
is inflammation, TNF-alpha signaling.
We see decreased fatty acid metabolism, OXPHOS,
and the metabolites are altered. Arginine,
proline, the urea cycle, creatine, creatinine,
and what goes up, even in the blood, is ceramides,
cholesterol, and triglycerides.
Is this one of the explanations why cancer patients have the
association of cardiovascular disease?
Everyone just says it's the treatment.
No, they're set up from the beginning.
Cancer causes all of these
complications. And then when you add the treatment, it
really accelerates the damage.
So if you see cholesterol and all these factors, we then did
Bodipy staining,
and here you could see the liver is all fatty liver.
Osteosarcoma, the liver is fatty liver.
And if you do look at patients themselves with
pancreatic cancer,
they also have fatty liver. And those
that develop lung Mets, not liver Mets, they have
the same signals with decreased OXPHOS and
fatty acid metabolism.
In mice, when we give EVPs every other day up to
four weeks,
we could give this with different tumor models.
We always can generate fatty liver disease
and upregulate inflammatory and TNF-alpha and
downregulate the exact same things, OXPHOS and
fatty acid metabolism.
Then we can inject these particles separately.
Here's the exomeres. You could see they all together
can cause fatty liver disease over a four-week period,
but especially the exomeres that are causing
more fatty liver metabolic
dysfunction.
Here, the Kupffer cell's the master cell.
So if we treat with claudin A and get rid of it,
all these exomeres especially can't bind to the
Kupffer cell,
and you don't generate fatty liver disease.
And it's TNF-alpha that's the main player that's
upregulated after exomere education,
especially. So if we inhibit TNF-alpha,
you can also block fatty liver disease.
At the EV level,
surprisingly, there's a lot of saturated fatty acids
like palmitate, which is also becoming a hot
molecule for metastasis studies.
Sarah Marie Phan is one of them who has shown
that palmitate really promotes metastases.
And normal vesicles don't have palmitate
so much being expressed. Palmitate
then can bind to the toll-like receptors
that are present on these Kupffer cells.
Not only was all these metabolites
upset with
these tumor types, but also the cytochrome
P450 system. We could get liver
slices, you put the drugs.
Normally, this should be the metabolic acetaminophen,
such as Tylenol,
and so it's only 50% efficient.
So all liver-dependent metabolic drugs are
affected.
And this is important for our patients with chemotherapy,
such as doxorubicin.
If you're a healthy mouse and you give doxorubicin,
your ejection fraction goes to 50% to 55%.
Those mice can recover. If the mice have fatty
liver disease induced by
these EVPs,
the ejection fraction is much worse.
It's about 40%, and you start having heart
damage.
So this is between the cholesterol and the
treatment and the baseline fatty liver
disease. This is explaining the number
one factor how our cancer patients die.
We say, "Oh, you survived the cancer.
So and so died of heart disease five years later."
No, the heart disease was related to the cancer.
So all our pediatric patients, sadly--
I took care of all these kids with brain tumors. We got through the worst.
College, they did well. They're all dying at 30 to
35 now of cardiovascular disease.
And so here's this pathway. Tumor
EVPs, we have to know which tumor type,
like the ones that are all lung-tropic metastatic
models. And as I mentioned, toll-like
receptor four
binds the palmitate. You have
TNF-alpha,
and you have problems with drug metabolism as
well.
This goes beyond just the liver. So we're failing to
metabolize the chemotherapy,
but this affects your whole immune system.
T-cells cannot function if there's no creatine,
creatinine.And arginine present.
That all goes down to zero when you have cancer.
So also, we think we're really enhancing the
cardiovascular disease component.
So as a reminder,
when you have a pre-metastatic lung like in, excuse me,
liver with pancreatic cancer, we have to worry about
thrombosis in the lung.
When you have tumors that metastasize to the
lung, you have a pre-metastatic lung, and the liver's not
normal. You have a fatty liver.
And so the therapeutic strategy now is we have to target the
primary tumor, we have to target the pre-metastatic niche, and
we have to target the systemically impacted organ.
And I just wanted to end showing some exciting
new data. I'm just showing how we can target the
primary tumor and possibly metastases.
Now, instead of using the ugly tumor exosomes, we're going to
get back at the cancer and give them activated T
cell EVs.
And you could see here they have very high extracellular
vesicle DNA present, which we're finding out
is very important for immune cell to immune cell
recognition.
If we inject these activated EVs, we can isolate them in
mice from lymph nodes and spleen,
put them in animals with cancer. They like
going to the lymph nodes,
so that's the non-activated EVs as well as the activated
ones. And they like to go to the tumor, which most
extracellular vesicles don't go back to the primary tumor.
Here's GBM. They're going through the blood-brain
barrier into the brain tumors. So it's very
exciting, and it's the tumor cells taking them up mostly,
not macrophages. So tumor EVs and a lot of
the other EVs are taken up by macrophages.
Here we're showing dendritic cells and tumor
cells are taking them up.
When we use them for treatment in mice with pancreatic
cancer,
we let the tumor grow a week, and then we just do five
intravenous treatments.
You could see we could really regress the tumor.
So here's treating with anti-PD-1.
It doesn't do much for pancreatic cancer.
We use activated T cells. It's doing a lot more,
but the activation with activated T
cell EVs also upregulate PD-1. We
could use the combination, and we get no tumor growth as long
as we do these five treatments.
Eventually, the tumors do grow, but they live
30 to 40 days more. So now we're doing longer
treatments, and the animals are living with their cancer.
We
have tertiary lymph node structures present.
For the distant metastases and systemic disease,
Mikala and I were working together, we could use PAD4
inhibitors, block the NETs in the lung.
What do we do about the fatty liver?
We could give TNF alpha or block palmitic
acid packaging in the EVs. But now we're really
focusing on the metabolism and
trying to improve cholesterol metabolism in the liver as a
drug.
For liver mets, again, you could prevent these NETs
in the liver, but we got to worry about the thrombosis,
so we could use CXCL13 inhibitors
or use these beta-2 inhibitors that we hopefully will
develop soon.
So in summary,
we think the integrins are critical on the
EVPs establishing organotropic
metastases,
but now they look like they have an additional role in systemic disease,
including thrombosis.
We think the exomeres in the models that you have
more lung metastases,
we have to really reprogram and get the liver back to
shape for all the reasons I explained.
So we believe, and we're now
doing these experiments in mice, these multi-organ
therapies.
We're extremely excited with some of the initial results
that we have.
And as the Princess Takamatsu really encouraged
international collaboration,
we're currently working with six different countries
in Europe and several labs in Sweden and Belgium.
Here we have Asia well represented with the Yuko
Hoshino from Japan.
We have our colleagues, two of them are here
from Israel that we're excited about.
And we're working in Ghana, Brazil, and Canada.
And just to remind, Canada is a country, it's not a state.
So I want to thank Serena, who's right here
in the second row in the front, who's just brilliant,
and Gang also. I'm very fortunate because this award
represents all the brilliant minds together.
It's so much fun doing research. You can't do it
alone.
And especially, I want to thank Princess Takamatsu
herselfAnd her legacy, I think if she was
here today, she would be so happy to see all of you
and what progress we've made and what the AACR has
done.
Thank you.
So thank you all for supporting this
lectureship,
and I'll be glad to answer some questions. Thank you.
David, as people come to their microphones, a quick question for you.
I'm intrigued by the cachexia connection.
To what degree is composition of the
NETs
in part responsible for the type of subsequent dysfunction?
Or if not the NETs, is there tropism for the different sizes
of particles that impact
cardiovascular, fatty liver, metabolic cachexia, blah, blah, blah?
Yeah. For cachexia, each kind of system
is kind of a surprise journey here.
So we would think tumor exosomes or
exomeres would go to muscle and heart.
To some small degree, they go to the heart, and
they simply don't go to the muscle.
Why some people like Cyrus Shahard thinks the muscle is an
anti-metastatic organ. Instead, we're
finding that the tumor EVPs are going to other
organ sites, and those organ sites now
go to the muscle and heart and brain.
Oh.
So it's like a second stop.
Got it.
Sergio?
Okay. I have a question about cardiovascular
complications. So it may be cardiomyocyte
toxicity, atherosclerosis, thrombosis, or anything
else. Did you specifically look what is affected and
what is not by EVs?
Yes. So that's something we're actively working with
James Lowe, who's a cardiologist and also a
researcher. So we don't know exactly
all those things that you mentioned.
We are also looking at brown fat,
because when you remove brown fat, the heart really has a lot
of problems with arrhythmias and such.
And so we think the EVs might be going to the brown
fat, dysregulating the communication between brown
fat and heart also.
Over here.
Thank you for a nice presentation.
I'm from the Ohio State University-
Nice
... Dr. Pollock's lab.
My question is that if
you remove the primary tumor in early
stage, how long can those EV keep
influencing the
other organs? Thank you.
Yes, so
that's a question if you move it very
early, then those tumor-associated
EVPs go down like a week later in humans
and in mice.
But if you
don't catch it early and then remove the tumor, as you know,
you can promote metastases, and that's where we find a lot
of tumor cells now are circulating or
are in lymph nodes or in bone marrow.
And then unfortunately, those tumor
EVPs persist in the blood.
So very early you do get rid of it, so it would be
best for early cancer detection as soon as possible to
remove these primary tumors and remove the
EVPs.
Thank you.
Akash Patnai from University of Chicago.
Congratulations on outstanding-
Thank you
... body of work. I was wondering about the mechanism for the
activated T cell EVs. You said they were taken up by the tumor
cells. Could you comment on what you think is happening
mechanistically to control the tumors?
Yes. So that paper is coming out in less than
two weeks in "Cancer Cell," so we're very excited about all
the steps involved. And so
non-activated and activated T cell EVs
can get to dendritic cells and tumors.
Again, here we go again, it's another integrin,
and so that's alpha L beta 2 integrin,
and they're binding to the ICAM positive sites, which are
highly expressed on tumors
and on dendritic cells. But really the
unique part is the activated T cell EVs also
package granzyme B,
and the non-activated ones don't, and the granzyme B
actually disturbs the nuclear membrane.
And we usually don't see EVs getting into the
nucleus. They usually hang out in the perinuclear
cytoplasmic side.
Here they go to the nucleus, and they go to the
euchromatin area of the nucleus where they can
upregulate antigen presentation genes,
and it's the donor DNA that's being upregulated,
not the recipient cell. So there's no gene insertion
taking place. So mechanistically, we're still trying to figure out
how this all happens.
Thank you.
Over here.
Hi, David.
Yes.
That's wonderful.
Hi, Adriana.
Yesterday, I went to an interesting lecture showing that, for instance, physical
exercise can modulate exosomes. I told you a little bit
about it.
Yes
And I was wondering if you can sort of
monitor prevention or intervention
in a tumor that could be metastatic, and maybe your
exomere or different kind of exosomes can be
used to monitor
intervention-
Exactly
... of this type.
Yes. So we're actually also studying exercise.
I don't know why. I hate exercise, but the postdoc
wanted to study it,
and
he's actually showing in normal mice exercising,
and we haven't published it yet, the EVPs are coming from
the brain and the thymus gland, and they're going from one immune organ
to the next.
And so that's normal. And so you could
restore fatty liver disease. And so when he puts
cancer in, they're competing with the tumor EVs for these
pre-metastatic sites and all the other systemic
effects that I mentioned.
And so we're
confirming all this in patients, working with Lee Jones,
who's here in California, who has thousands
of breast cancer women on chronic exercise schedules.
We're very excited because we
can
measure the loss of tumor exosomes and
reestablishment of healthy immune exosomes in these
cancer patients.
I just want to add, acute exercise actually is a bad thing.
If you decide to go skiing or whatever,
we showed in the mice
that actually promotes metastases and doesn't-
You got mice skiing?
Yeah.
Exactly.
Thank you.
So yes, we're very interested in the effects of chronic exercise and how
it supports immune function and blocks tumor exosome
uptake.
Thank you.
Over here.
Hello. I'm here.
Yeah.
People from UBC, Canada.
I'm allowed to say now.
First of all, congratulations for your outstanding work and well-deserved award.
I'm a bone person, and I saw in your imaging some of the EVs are capturing
bone, but you didn't mention much because you're trying to go by
it, or do you see-
No, no.
I saw them in the
diaphysis of the long bone, which is not the metastatic niche for most
cancers, so I don't know if you have to comment, something to comment about.
Yes. So a lot of these EVPs are
going to the bone, and those
bone marrow cells that are taking them up, actually, that's how we first
described the pre-metastatic niche, as I showed you in the first
slide.
Now they promote recruitment, activation, and they
leave the bone, and they don't establish so
much,
these EVPs, the metastatic bone niche, unless you
use the metastatic bone niche models.
And
now some people think the larger
extracellular vesicles are more important in bone mets than these
small ones that I showed you today.
So now we're working with another group and
comparing
each one's role in the bone.
Thank you.
We're using models specifically that metastasize to the
spine. Patients don't usually have mets to the long bone.
But these EVPs, which are bad, fuse with
those cells and recruit them to
pre-metastatic sites in the lung.
Thank you.
Here in the middle, and I apologize, but in the interest of time, this will have to
be the last question. But Dr. Lydon will be very happy to stay
after and talk to you. So here, please, in the middle.
Hi, David, and congratulations on this award.
Thank you.
I wonder if you have a sense on the relative contribution of
cancer-associated fibroblasts in the production of EVPs,
particularly in tumors like the pancreatic cancer
that are enriching in these fibroblasts.
Yes. So we actually have Lee in
the lab studying CAFs specifically.
And we've established fibroblast lines from
patients as well as organoids, and we compare them.
And they're packaging a lot of different cargo,
and they're actually going to different places.
And so we're getting ready to write that up.
So the pancreatic organoid EVs go
to the typical sites, liver, omentum, adrenal
gland, but the fibroblast ones are going to other
organ sites, and they also have different
reprogramming. The pancreatic cancer are more
pro-inflammatory. The CAF EVs
affect the metabolism
more and dysregulate normal
metabolic pathways.
All right. Thank you so much, David.
Please join me in acknowledging and congratulating Dr.
Lydon.
Thank you.
Congrats.